Inventory comes in many shapes and sizes, depending on the type of business you run.
There are three main categories of inventory though:
The first is merchandise that your business resells,...
...like the items for sale in your shop...
...plus all the stock you've got stored in your warehouse, for instance.
In other words,...
...all the items you've bought with the intention of selling to your customers,...
...either as is or combined with other products.
Then there are products that your business might install.
Plumbers, for example, might sell gaskets and new faucets as part of a repair job.
And then there are goods your business makes or manufactures.
Now, here are a couple things that are not inventory:...
Equipment and supplies you've bought to run your business,...
...such as work tools or vehicles, and stationery; those are not inventory.
These are usually accounted for as assets or expenses.
And some dropshipping businesses don't have inventory either.
It's usually not considered inventory if you sell goods online...
...that you never actually take ownership of,...
...as in some cases when a third party delivers the goods directly...
...from their warehouse to your customers.